Game of Thrones is back baby so that  means so a week from next week will be  breaking down the latest episodes  overanalyzing fan theories and obsessing  over Littlefinger well that's what I'll  be doing  [Music]  tomorrow Dave and I will be coming at  you from our new home the GameSpot  universe YouTube channel so make sure  you subscribe so you don't miss out  every Monday we'll have features about  the show we'll be talking about what  George RR Martin's up to and we have you  covered for everything I said fire our  small Council meets every Monday and we  want you to get involved tweet us with  the hashtag G SOT or fly on down to the  comment section below we would love to  hear your thoughts comments and theories  so that's Monday's on the Gainesville  universe YouTube channel all men must  subscribe